we've been doing will is talk we're  talking to actors from their own homes  we're just seeing you know anything  they've nicked from film sets let's call  it memorabilia yes deep have you got  anything good at hand  oh I've got a couple of things I've got  I hope you can see it this first item is  my my Channel 4 News ring from anchorman  which is uh yes Ron Burgundy wore this  on every day of filming which is a  classic and then I have one other item  which which is in a special cardboard  box here and these are my prosthetic  testicles from step back very lifelike  and I have brought these out much to the  horror at many a dinner party I  presented these so yeah these these fake  testicles were what we put on a  Brennan's drumkit tails there's gonna be  a screen grab of that that's gonna go  viral just some bollocks in your face  [Music]  you